So let's get started in the qualitative
processing phase.
Okay, so welcome back to the desk.
We're going to continue now with our
second step for qualitative processing.
And actually this is our second and final
step in the qualitative processing phase.
So let's get stuck in.
So just as a reminder,
In the first stage of our qualitative
analysis processing,
we engaged in the identification of a
particular company's key performance
indicators or KPIs
and what the management operating plan,
the MOP, of that company was through
inference of those KPIs.
Whenever you're going through the
qualitative processing in any stock,
you need to actually layer additional
qualitative work on top of that.
And this breaks down into five main areas.
So we're going to be looking in this video
at earnings call transcripts.
We're going to be looking at management
track record.
We'll look at the board of directors of a
company.
We're going to be looking at insider stock
and stock option ownership and also the
trading of insider stock and stock
options.
And we're also going to be looking at
research analyst estimates and the analyst
range and ratings for stocks.
So let's start with earnings call
transcripts.
It's a very important resource when going
through the qualitative process for any
stock.
So once you've gone through financial
statements and company presentations and
you've identified company KPIs,
what you need to do now is tie up all of
the loose ends around those KPIs.
So you can actually typically get a lot or
all of the main KPIs from earnings call
transcripts if they're not available on
the investor relations website.
This is always on a case by case basis and
in a particular situation, a particular
stock management may not be communicating
those KPIs to the market in written form,
but they may be communicating them
verbally.
This is you tying up the loose ends by
looking at earnings call transcripts.
So you have to double check them.
So to make sure that there's no stone left
unturned, go straight to the earnings call
transcripts next.
So what is an actual earnings call
transcript?
Well, it's when management communicate
their results on a conference call
and they do this verbally to shareholders
and the public on the day that the company
releases their quarterly earnings report.
And these earnings calls are transcribed
and they are uploaded to the company
website.
They're uploaded online and they are made
publicly available.
So usually what you're going to see is
you're going to see the head of investor
relations hosting the conference call.
And both the CEO and the CFO will
literally tell you what numbers to focus
on.
Now, of course, we have to use a bit of
common sense here and be a little bit
cautious.
Of course, earnings calls are scripted and
rehearsed.
It's the information that management wants
you to focus on.
However, at this stage of our analysis for
our purposes right now,
it's simply to identify the KPIs that we
haven't identified yet from company
presentations.
The trick here and to do it quickly and
efficiently is to scan the earnings call
transcript
and just let your eye zoom in on the
numbers and pay less attention to all of
the mumbo jumbo and noise in the rest of
the transcript.
So how do you actually go about doing
this?
Well, we've got an example here.
We're looking at Abercrombie and Fitch,
ANF.
We're looking at their KPIs and management
operating plan.
And this is where we're going to be doing
further work using this example of ANF,
Abercrombie and Fitch.
What you're going to do is use some common
sense.
You're going to get a great shortcut by
just going to Google and typing in the
stock or the stock code
with the extension earnings call
transcripts.
And you'll get a lot of search results and
most probably the most recent ones right
at the top of the page on Google.
There's obviously going to be multiple
sources that document this information.
What we want you to focus on here is
obviously the process.
In years from now, the process will still
be the same.
Sources may be different.
But right now we have a search result at
the top of the page where we can see on
the top of the search results on Google
website seekingalpha.com.
And we just click through and we take a
look.
And what do we find when we click through?
Yes, we get a full history of Abercrombie
and Fitch quarterly earnings and earnings
call transcripts.
Not only that, but we also get the full
presentation released by the company that
accompanies the transcribed upload of the
earnings call.
So here we have clicked through on the top
result and we get to the page where we
have the Abercrombie and Fitch Q4 2020
earnings call transcript.
And we can see who was on the call from
the company.
So the company participants.
And not only that, we can see other
conference call participants, namely the
research analysts at the various
investment banks.
And as well, both research companies and
brokerage companies.
What you will find is that the format of
earnings calls, earnings conference calls
across the market, across various stocks,
follow pretty much the same format.
So the head of investor relations or
representative of investor relations will
introduce the call.
And then the CEO and CFO will come on
later.
And what do we see here?
We see Pam Quintiliano, who's from
investor relations, introducing the call.
And then after the introduction, turning
it over to the CEO, Fran Horowitz.
Now, what are we interested in?
We are obviously interested in identifying
key performance indicators, KPIs from the
earnings call transcripts.
We're looking for what's important from
the language and where they are pointing
us.
What direction are they pointing us in?
What numbers are they pointing us at that
are important as business drivers behind
revenue and earnings?
Well, what you will find in most cases,
the vast, vast majority of cases, is that
the CEO will start pointing you in the
direction of the KPIs that matter.
So if we look at what Fran Horowitz starts
talking about immediately, what's Fran
actually talking about?
Well, here's what she's saying.
So if we just look at the paragraph, her
opening paragraph where she starts talking
about numbers after the niceties are out
of the way, she says,
Looking back on 2020, I am proud of our
accomplishments and the positive change
that we drove.
Okay?
That's great.
That's all mumbo jumbo so far.
There's no numbers around that.
Then she gets into the number, the numbers
that she wants to talk about immediately
that are important.
So here's what she's saying.
Despite the difficult operating
environment.
Yes, 2020 was the COVID year.
She's saying we grew digital penetration
to 54% of revenue from 33% last year.
So using common sense, what does that tell
us?
Digital penetration is obviously an
important KPI to this company.
How do we know that?
Because literally the CEO is pointing to
it immediately in the earnings conference
call.
It's the first number that she mentions.
So it has to be an important number.
Additionally, in that paragraph, what
she's saying.
She's saying they removed 1.1 million
gross square feet or 17% from our global
base.
What does that mean?
It means they are closing retail stores.
They are reducing their retail store
capacity by 17%.
So taking that into context with digital
penetration increasing.
What does that mean?
They are moving from physical stores to
online sales.
These are two obviously very important
KPIs to the current management operating
plan of Abercrombie and Fitch.
Additionally, she is saying that they
expanded their gross profit margin by 110
basis points.
Which we know is the end result of KPIs
such as increasing digital penetration and
decreasing gross square feet for retail
stores.
Gross profit margin is an end result based
on revenue and earnings.
So what she's saying here is that the
switch from physical retail stores to
digital and online sales has resulted in
an increase in gross profit margin.
Additionally, she is saying that they
fortified their balance sheet to the end
of the year and they've got 1.3 billion
dollars of liquidity.
Now what that definition of liquidity
means, you would go and have to do further
work on, but you have all of the balance
sheet metrics from earlier in the video
series to enable you to work that out.
But again, this is a end result metric.
This is something that ends up in the
financial statements.
It's not a KPI.
Remember KPIs are measures of performance
of the business that is driving revenue
and earnings.
So what we take from this so far on the
first page of the earnings call transcript
is that the increase and the rate of
increase of digital penetration to online
sales.
Versus removing or reducing gross square
feet for retail stores are important KPIs.
If we continue through the earnings call
transcript, we can go through some more
examples.
If we just allow our eye to zoom in to
what really matters, we can see Fran is
going through information here pertaining
to digital.
So results she's saying were driven by
digital, which grew 34% to $639 million,
making up 57% of sales.
They've continued to get year on year
improvements in website traffic.
And all of this has resulted in the best
digital gross margin rate in eight years.
We also start finding in the earnings call
transcript references to some acronyms
that we would actually obviously go and
have to look into further.
So she's saying here that we realized
higher year over year AUR.
Obviously you would go away and figure
that out and figure out what it is.
No matter what sector you're in, no matter
what stocks you're looking at, you're
obviously going to have to do a bit of
extra work, a bit of digging to find out
the definitions of certain metrics.
We also have a reference to inventories
and the level of inventories down 7% on a
5% revenue decline.
Inventories are a classic KPI in the
retail sector and obviously quite
important.
And also the quality of inventories is
also important as well.
What we also pick up on here is a
reference to all four brands that the
company has in its portfolio.
So yes, this may be new information at
this stage.
So we pick up that the amount of brands in
a portfolio and how profitable those
brands are in aggregate and relative to
each other is a KPI that's important as
well.
We also pick up on another KPI called
average transaction value.
And that is from both new and existing
customers.
We make a note of that and we put it in
our KPI list and we do more work on it.
We can see as well that there's also a
reference to a metric and it's actually an
estimate for a metric called new to file
customers in digital penetration, digital
growth.
And she's referencing that the channel
grew over 35%.
Again, this metric or this estimate of new
to file customers, this definition of new
to file customers, you would go away,
figure out what the definition of that
actually is.
And if it's a genuine KPI, stick it in
your KPI list and do more work on it and
see how it's been trending over time.
Then on the next page, we see a reference
to a focus on assortment architecture.
That's really just a fancy way of saying
in retail land what items they are
marketing, what items they are pushing and
the mix of the sales from the items that
they are selling.
And she's saying that the strategy, the
focus has been on selling high margin must
haves and their top 30 items.
And it's continuing to pay off in terms of
strategy.
So with this particular operating plan,
this would actually be part of an overall
management operating plan, but it can't
really be a key performance.
Indicator because we can't put numbers
around that moving forward in the earnings
call transcript to the next page.
We see a reference again to the decrease
in square footage of retail or physical
stores, but now we're getting a bit more
meat on the bone.
So she's telling us that in 2020, there
was a closure of 137 locations, which
added up to 1.1 million gross square feet
or the 17% of the base that we saw in the,
on the first page.
And she's also telling us that they closed
129 of the 137 locations, 129 non flagship
stores, which made up 850,000 of the 1.1
million.
So what can we infer from that?
Well, we can infer potentially that the
strategy here in detail is to close non
flagship stores and keep the flagship
stores open.
So again, we've got plenty of KPIs and
numbers to work with here.
We've got our gross square feet number,
the percentage of the base.
So that's the speed per quarter at which
they're reducing and what they're actually
reducing.
We've got the amount of locations.
We can use that as a metric, a KPI going
forward and the amount of non flagship
stores and flagship stores from those
locations.
We can use them as a KPI as well and use
them going forward to measure the
effectiveness of the management operating
plan and to gauge an expectation of
revenue and earnings in the future.
Again, the CEO here is literally telling
us what's important to the management
operating plan by saying aligning square
footage with digital penetration
is the most important lever to maintain
and improve profitability.
So guys, she is literally telling you here
what the management operating plan is, how
they're actually going to achieve an
increase in revenue and earnings and all
of the numbers to focus on in achieving
that.
Now, the great thing about earnings call
transcripts and going through this process
is that many of the KPIs that you're going
to obtain by doing this work on a
particular stock are going to be the same
KPIs for many other stocks in the sector.
There is definitely going to be a large
overlap.
So the good news, the good thing about
this is that you only have to do the work
once on a stock, create your KPI dashboard
and many of the KPIs that you have on your
dashboard are going to apply across the
sector to other stocks.
Now, of course, what you're going to find
is when you do this work and go through
the processes, additional to KPIs that
apply across the sector, there are also
going to be KPIs that are idiosyncratic to
that particular stock.
You have to be mindful of this and
separate out KPIs that apply across the
sector to other stocks and KPIs that apply
only to a particular stock.
So when you're identifying KPIs for a
particular stock, you can obviously also
compare them to other stocks in the same
sector.
And of course, always be mindful why
you're at this stage in the first place,
why you're actually at the qualitative
stage and doing the work.
It's because you've identified a positive
or negative outlier from the quantitative
phase.
So always be asking yourself that question
in the back of your mind.
It's good discipline.
Why is this stock on a premium or a
discount to the sector?
It may lie in a particular KPI.
The answer may lie in one of the KPIs or a
few of the KPIs that you're looking at,
whether they are good or bad.
Now, I know what you'll be thinking at
this stage.
Wouldn't it be great if I could get my
hands on a book or a cheat sheet or a
shortcut or a hack to know all of the KPIs
in every single sector forever throughout
time.
And you may be thinking of asking us the
question, Anton, will you be providing me
with all the KPIs for every GIX and NAICS
sector so I never have to do any work or
learn the information myself or go through
any processes myself?
Well, the answer to that question,
unfortunately, is a flat no.
No.
Why?
Because over time, KPIs may change and you
need to learn the process.
That's the most important thing.
At the end of the day, you have to be self
sustainable.
You have to have a good, solid work ethic
and you have to know and understand how to
process yourself so you can work smart and
not hard.
Don't be one of these people who always
looks for excuses and refuses to do the
work because you think you're entitled to
a shortcut and for everybody else to do
the work for you.
Unfortunately, there's no way you can
climb the competency hierarchy and become
professional trader level unless you do
all of these processes yourself and they
become second nature to you.
Now, seeing as though we are in the retail
sector, let's have a look at a dashboard
that we may have gotten if we went through
the Abercrombie and Fitch processes for
qualitative analysis.
So if you went through the processes
where, for example, you went through the
Abercrombie and Fitch financial
statements.
So quarterlies and annuals.
You went through company presentations
from the investor relations website.
And you also went through a number of
earnings call transcripts, conference call
transcripts in the past.
You may have got to a dashboard that looks
something like this.
So here we've split it up and organized it
into categories of sales, inventory,
stores, brands and customers.
So in sales, we have same store sales,
sales per square foot.
We have that AUR metric that we identified
earlier.
That is actually average unit retail.
You can look at that definition in your
own time.
We have average sales per customer.
And we have online sales percentage versus
physical location.
So that's all in the category of sales.
In the category of inventory, we have an
average inventory number, inventory
turnover, stock turnover days and sell
through rates.
For physical retail stores, we have number
of locations at the end and beginning of
the final hour.
We have the number of locations at the
beginning of the financial period in
question.
We have the number of company owned
locations, number of franchises.
We have total space owned by the company
in square feet.
And we have total space leased by the
company in square feet.
And we have gross square feet for
aggregate retail stores.
Within the category of brands, we have the
number of brands within a portfolio.
And we have the number of store names.
And within customers, we have that metric
that we identified earlier.
New to file customers.
That is customers that are new in the
database.
So whenever you are doing your work in the
qualitative analysis phase, going through
these processes for a particular stock,
what's going to happen?
You're going to end up with a dashboard
that looks something like this.
And this applies to any stock in any
sector.
For a particular stock in a particular
sector, you're going to categorize all of
the KPIs across the different categories
that they relate to.
What we are interested in as traders in
the qualitative phase is metrics that we
can actually put numbers to.
So we want to be able to measure with
numbers, with data, through time, KPIs and
performance of the business.
And use those KPIs to infer a management
operating plan and to predict with a
probabilistic analysis the trend and an
expectation of positive or negative
surprise in the future.
And what we mean by that is a positive or
negative surprise to future revenue and
earnings.
That is the end result of KPIs trending
positively or negatively or even turning.
So Abercrombie & Fitch, Q4 numbers, Q4
earnings called transcript and
presentations were a classic example for
traders and portfolio managers to be on
top of KPIs and an inferred management
operating plan.
If you go back a number of slides in the
video, you will see that Abercrombie &
Fitch reported their full year.
And Q4 numbers, fourth quarter numbers for
2020, they reported them on the date the
2nd of March 2021.
And if we just look at a stock chart from
the time, we can have a look at the
performance of Abercrombie & Fitch ANF
stock during that time period.
So if we just segment this performance
based on quarters, if we have a look at Q4
2020, we're looking at the months October,
November, December, we can pretty much say
that the stock went from $15 a share to
$20 a share in that quarter, even above
$20.
But being conservative, if we were on top
of the KPIs, but being conservative, if we
were on top of the KPIs, on top of the
trend, on top of the quantitative, and
also on top of our macro trends, we
probably would have captured that move.
And that is a $5 per share move on a $15
starting point.
So $15 to $20.
So we're getting the stock price moving up
by 33%.
If we then look at the first quarter in
2021 after getting a sideways movement in
December in 2020, we can see that the
stock rallies very significantly all the
way into full year and Q4 numbers, which
remember were the 2nd of March 2021.
And you can see after they report, the
stock actually rallies quite a lot as
well.
So again, like in Q4 2020, if in Q1 2021,
we were on top of everything here, our
macro, our quantitative, our qualitative,
our KPIs, and we were on top of the trend
of what was happening in this stock.
We knew the management operating plan.
We were on top of it.
We may have had a position going into
numbers because revenue and earnings is
the end result.
So if we got into this stock in January
2021 at say 22 and a half, and then we got
out of it at say 32 and a half in March,
we would have made around 45%.
And yes, in both of these quarters,
Abercrombie and Fitch, as an example, in
both of these quarters, this fits within
our 20 to 60 day time horizon, obviously,
because we are segmenting by quarters.
And for the record, Abercrombie and Fitch
would have been categorized in our
analysis as a turnaround story.
This stock back in 2007 and in 2011 was
trading at above $70 a share.
And from 2011 onwards, the company, the
stock had a miserable decade and the
turnaround didn't actually come until
2021.
So Abercrombie and Fitch, classic example
of a turnaround story and a great example
of identifying KPIs, inferring a
management operating plan, and also how
everything fits together from our
qualitative analysis, our quantitative
analysis as well.
And also with an assumption, a macro
assumption in the background that we were
leaning towards being bullish.
So that is earnings called transcripts
guys, fit them in, obviously with your
previous analysis for the qualitative
phase, when you're looking at financial
statements, and also company
presentations, company presentations and
transcripts.
Definitely the most important in
identifying KPIs and inferring a
management operating plan.
When you're identifying KPIs and inferring
the management operating plan, we want
metrics.
We want data.
We want meat on the bone.
We want to be able to quantify with
numbers, what is driving revenue and
earnings.
What is behind revenue and earnings and
creating revenue and earnings.
How is the company actually measuring its
business.
And when you get good at this, you'll be
able to do it very, very quickly and
create your KPI and inferred MOP
management operating plan dashboard.
Now, something else that we need to look
at that is part of the qualitative
assessment is management track record.
Now, when we're looking at the management
of a public company, this is obviously not
like identifying KPIs where we can put
numbers to the business and our analysis.
It does fall into the category of
qualitative work, and it gives us a very
good idea of the quality of the team
behind the numbers, behind the business.
And here, we're going to have a look at an
example where we're looking at the company
HubSpot.
And with any company, you'll be able to
get the leadership team, any public
company, you'll be able to get it on their
website.
And you'll be able to look into the
backgrounds of all the key leadership
team, all the key management team at the
top of the tree.
And additional to the company website,
there's multiple resources online,
obviously, where you can dig around about
the backgrounds of all the key leadership
members of the team.
These guys are at the top of the tree of a
public company, and therefore, they are
publicly facing.
So, you're going to get information on
these guys publicly.
It's going to be online.
You can Google around, and you can access
many resources to get as much information
as you can as possible.
Additionally, there's a certain lens in
which you would view a management team or
leadership team through as a trader
portfolio manager.
And there's certain processes that you
would go through to learn all of this
qualitative information properly.
And we're going to go through these steps
now with HubSpot as the example.
So, the first thing you would do is
identify who is the alpha, who is the CEO,
who's running the company.
And you would ask a whole bunch of
questions of that person.
How long have they been with the company?
What is his or her relevant experience?
Have they actually led a team before?
And if so, which teams?
What were the success rates?
Have they been involved in previous
corporate success stories?
How much stock and stock options do they
actually own?
Are they invested in the success, the
future success of the company?
And also, what pedigree do they have?
Where did they go to school?
And what did they actually study at
school?
These are the questions that you should
ask of all key management personnel that
are in leadership roles in a public
company.
So, here for HubSpot, we have the CEO,
Brian Halligan.
And he's not just the CEO of the company.
He is also the co-founder, which tells us
there were other co-founders as well.
So, Brian Halligan, he's a co-founder and
the current CEO of HubSpot.
So, how long has he been at the company?
He's been there since the very beginning.
Now, what's his actual experience?
Well, previously, before starting HubSpot,
he was a venture partner at Longworth
Ventures and a VP of Sales at Groove
Networks, which was acquired by Microsoft.
So, if we're asking these questions,
what's his relevant experience?
Has he actually led a team before?
And has he been involved in previous
corporate success stories?
The answers are very obvious.
He's got experience in the industry.
He's led teams.
And he's also had previous corporate
success by building a company and selling
it to Microsoft.
Now, we're going to get on to stock and
stock options ownership a bit later on.
But answering the last question, where do
they go to school?
And what did they actually do at school?
Well, he went to the University of Vermont
and did a BSEE.
And he did an MBA at MIT's Sloan School of
Management.
Where now he's also a senior lecturer and
he's teaching a course called Scaling
Entrepreneurial Ventures.
So, as we're going through our qualitative
work, our first step, things are looking
pretty good with Brian Halligan as the CEO
of HubSpot.
So, all of our questions that we've seeked
answers to so far that we can get answers
to at this stage have been answered
positively.
So, the next step we would take, after
we've looked at the CEO, is to look at
other people in management.
And the next step we take is to identify
primary or key management positions.
And what we're trying to do is identify
the primary beaters.
These are our lieutenants.
The primary beaters are our lieutenants.
They are the key members of the management
team that are actually, on a daily basis,
implementing the plans of management.
So, in the HubSpot example, we start with
this guy, Dharmesh Shah, who's Chief
Technical Officer, and he's also a
co-founder.
So, there's a question mark actually here
over Dharmesh Shah, whether he is a legacy
alpha or not, whether he is subservient to
the CEO or not.
We would have to do further work on that.
But certainly, the rest of these guys
outside Dharmesh Shah, we can pretty much
say with high probability that these guys
are management lieutenants, senior
management lieutenants.
They are primary beaters.
And they report to the alpha, Brian
Halligan.
So, all of these guys and their
backgrounds are very, very important.
It's very important that the primary
beaters are extremely effective.
So, we start with the CFO, the Chief
Financial Officer.
And in the HubSpot example, this is Kate
Bucher.
So, we're answering the question here, who
is actually looking after the books?
Next up, we've got the Chief Product
Officer, which is Christopher O'Donnell.
He obviously has a very important role in
the company at management level.
And he is spearheading product development
at HubSpot.
Why is he really important?
Well, in any business without a product,
there simply are no customers.
Next up is the Chief Architect, a guy
called Whitney Sorensen.
In this business, he's extremely important
at the management level because he is
spearheading the engineering effort for
the product.
So, the engineering effort behind the
product and without good engineering,
there is no product.
So, HubSpot is a CRM, a client
relationship management tool.
And if you want a first class product in
that industry, you need first class
engineering.
So, the Chief Architect, Whitney Sorensen,
is definitely a key member of the
management team
and is a Lieutenant Primary Beta reporting
to the CEO.
Next up at Primary Beta management level
is Corporate and Business Development,
Andrew Lindsay.
This guy is in charge of the expansion
strategy of the company, which is
obviously extremely key to growing the
business.
And next up after that is the CMO, Chief
Marketing Officer, Kip Bodnar.
In any business, in any industry, for a
particular company, growth is simply not
possible without killer marketing.
So, we go through the phase of identifying
our key lieutenants, our primary betas
that report to the alpha.
And then we also, by default, identify
secondary betas, so secondary or less than
key management positions.
These guys also report to the CEO, but
their roles are less important than the
primary betas.
So, we have our Chief Customer Officer,
Chief People Officer, Executive VP Revenue
Operations, General Counsel,
Executive VP Customer Success, and Chief
Security Officer, and Senior VP for
Engineering.
So, the lens in the way that you have to
view management and the processes that you
go through,
at the management level, you need to
identify who the key people are below the
CEO.
So, who are the primary betas?
And also, identify who are the hangers-on
or the people who have pretty much token
positions at management level.
So, who are the secondary betas?
Why?
Well, because it's the alpha and the
primary betas that drive the product, the
management operating plan, and the KPIs.
And this is what ultimately drives revenue
and earnings, and the success of the
company.
And for the record, in the hierarchy,
beneath the alpha, we identify the primary
and secondary betas,
but then there's also tertiary betas.
So, these are lower-level management
personnel, and we also have the workers,
which we call deltas.
So, when you're going to look at a
company's management, and you're actually
appraising the management track record,
you have to go through a process of
identifying who the key guys are.
So, this is a good template to use,
identify the alpha, split up the betas,
the lieutenants into primary and secondary
betas,
and appraise their backgrounds, appraise
their management track record.
In the HubSpot example, we can look at all
of the primary betas.
You can get all the information on their
backgrounds on the company website, and
you can even just start Googling their
names as well,
and hoarding information to appraise their
management track record.
Something else that you would likely be
very interested in when you're going
through the qualitative phase is who sits
on the board.
Who are the board of directors?
And something that you have to understand
here is that for a public company, the
board of directors is not supposed to be
subservient to the CEO and management.
What you have to look for when you're
assessing the board of directors is you
need to look for evidence of political
incest amongst betas.
How many of the betas are sitting on the
board, what is the overlap, and have a
look at additional personnel on the board
as well.
And what relationships they may or may not
have had in the past with primary and
secondary betas in management.
At the end of the day, the board of
directors is supposed to keep the CEO and
management in check.
So high integrity is required from the
board of directors.
We don't want to see lots of evidence of
political incest.
We only want to really see that if we're
thinking about shorting a stock.
So if we're looking at a negative outlier,
we would want to see evidence of political
incest.
But certainly, if we're looking to go
long, if we've identified a positive
outlier in a sector, we need high
integrity from the board.
So what do we get from HubSpot as our
example?
Well, we get a great situation.
We have great product, great engineering,
an awesome marketing effort, a very solid
expansion strategy, and across management,
we have a very strong management
background.
And as a bonus, we also have a board of
directors with high integrity.
And guess what?
This has all manifested itself into an
awesome business, an awesome company, and
a very, very good performing stock.
So obviously, when we look at stock price
performance, as we've looked at before in
multiple examples, in the context of a
trade idea, we obviously make some
assumptions here that at the time, you
will have been bullish on the macro
environment with a net long bias in your
portfolio.
You will have been bullish on the sector,
and you will have identified a particular
stock, in this example, HubSpot, as a
positive outlier in the sector.
So through your quant analysis,
identifying HubSpot as a positive outlier
in the sector.
And then, of course, you will have moved
on to the next level, and done the
qualitative analysis, and then decided the
timing was good, and you either bought the
stock as an outright long, or structured
it as a long option structure, utilizing
call options.
And if we look at two periods in recent
history from the time of recording, so if
we look at Q4 2020, and we look at Q1
2021, then we'll see some outperformance
and some big opportunity back then for
absolute return.
So if you imagine yourself sitting in
October 2020, so the beginning of October
2020, and you've done all your work on
HubSpot, it's not unreasonable to assume
that in Q4, you would have bought this
stock at around 300 or in the low 300s,
and sold it either in the high 300s or
around $400.
So within our 20 to 60 day time horizon,
as long short portfolio managers, and
returning roughly a 30, 33% return,
something like this.
So if you can see if you were either
coming into the new year in 2021, and
you'd missed that move, that's okay.
You may have come in and done your work
and realized that HubSpot was probably
still a buy at the time.
You may have also been in the position in
Q4 and traded out, and then you were faced
with the choice of looking to take a
position in something else, or even
restructuring the trade given the new
fundamentals or situation at the time in
the market.
It doesn't really matter if you just think
at the end of Q4, beginning of Q1, you
were faced with the choices, and one of
the choices is to just buy HubSpot or not.
And buying it for the 20 to 60 day time
horizon, obviously not as an investment.
Well, you would have had a slightly more
volatile or wild ride in Q1 2021, owning
HubSpot versus Q4 2020.
But it's not unreasonable to assume that
you would have captured about $100 of
performance in Q1, and making that $100
performance from a starting point of
around $400.
So making a roughly 25% return within the
20 to 60 day time horizon, which is
obviously very good.
And if you think about performance in
terms of absolute return in Q4 2020 and Q1
2021 in HubSpot, we are just talking here
about underlying performance in the stock.
So we're assuming here that you were just
owning the stock.
What if you did all your work, all the
stars were aligned, the timing was right,
and there were favorable option structures
that you could trade at the time, which
generally speaking, there usually is, as
long as you know what you're doing.
then of course that return can be levered
and you would make a much higher return
than the 30 33%
return in q4 from that move of $300 to
$400 and you'd make a lot more as well
even in q1 2021
from the $100 move of the $400 base so the
25% move in the underlying you'd make a
much higher
absolute return via option structures so
HubSpot provides a very very good
qualitative example here
and also a good example of a stock and and
the type of volatility and performance
over our 20 to 60
day time horizon that we're seeking to
achieve from long positive outlier
positions now remember guys
when we do look at examples they are just
examples and they're examples from the
past
to help you understand how we do things
and to understand the process this is not
an endorsement
for you to go out and go and buy HubSpot
think of it in the process that we're
looking at and
the process as a template and generate new
and original trade ideas and obviously it
needs
to be you that generates the ideas not us
or a third party or somebody else and
you're copy trading that's
just for idiots so please don't make the
rookie mistake of thinking examples in the
PTM video series
what we're doing here is showing you the
step-by-step process and at the moment we
are in the qualitative phase
and yes as we go along we're going to be
using examples to highlight what you
should be looking for
and also how everything fits together in
the process now the next step in the
qualitative phase
we will be looking at insider stock and
stock option ownership
and we're going to be using HubSpot again
as our example so we'll carry on looking
at HubSpot
for insider stock and stock option
ownership our source here is fidelity
which is all publicly available
information sources obviously will change
over time get used to the process and get
used to googling
keywords and phrases so keywords and
phrases like the name of the company and
ownership and insider
stock and stock option ownership if you
follow the process you'll find multiple
sources
sources and of course sources will change
over time and likely get better over time
so here when we look at the insider stock
and stock option ownership using fidelity
for HubSpot
at the time of recording we find that
Dharmesh Shah is by far the biggest
shareholder of the company
remember Dharmesh Shah is a co-founder
alongside the current CEO Brian Halligan
and Dharmesh Shah was our potential legacy
alpha and he is by far the largest
shareholder of the company
so when we realize this when we're going
through our processes if you see something
like this it's very likely
that the guy here Dharmesh Shah is the
real big daddy alpha or founder of the
company we obviously have to use some
discretion
and common sense here and just think of
ourselves at the time why isn't he the CEO
well maybe he just isn't a CEO type and
he's more of a builder or engineer
we can also do a simple further work and
work out what his stock is actually worth
at the time so Dharmesh Shah he owns just
over 1.5 million shares
so his worth his stock worth is around 861
million dollars and Brian Halligan his
stockholding is worth around 360 million
dollars
so between them the two co-founders
Dharmesh Shah and Brian Halligan they own
just over at the time 1.2 billion dollars
worth of stock
now we know that HubSpot is a New York
Stock Exchange listed company and they are
well past their IPO lockup period
which typically ranges from 90 to 180 days
so what's happening here is that Dharmesh
Shah and Brian Halligan they've chosen to
hold on to their stock well beyond the IPO
lockup period
now what also happens when you go through
this stage of the qualitative process is
that you'll discover that there's other
shareholders
that you may yet have not discovered in
the process so what we've done is we've
discovered that there's new people
involved in the company
in a shareholder capacity and what you can
do is is start collecting the information
on their share ownership and also on the
people themselves
so additional to the founders we do have
sizable stockholders of HubSpot we have
Donald J Sherman
who's the president he owns about 38
million dollars of stock we have John
Kinzer CFO he owns about 37 million
dollars of stock
uh we have Michael K Simon a director uh
he owns around 24 million dollars of the
stock
we have Hunter Madeley uh Hunter Madeley
owns around 18 million dollars of the
stock
so in your process you just go through
this and you list them and you work out
the worth of their stock
in the bigger picture these amounts of
stock in terms of notional dollar value
are actually very small in the bigger
picture
and what you can also do is start checking
the background of these people uh and
figure out their experience
and integrity in the industry so you can
see on the page here uh we've done this uh
for all of these guys
uh so on this on this page we have uh
Donald Sherman John Kinzer uh and Michael
K Simon
and what we've got here actually is their
LinkedIn profiles so yes you can just
google these people
uh and you will find sources of their
current occupation and their background
and figure out
how and why they're actually involved as
shareholders at the company so you can see
here uh Donald J Sherman
uh he's now the ex-president and he
actually stepped down in 2020 uh and he
was the former president
and COO chief operating officer uh and
currently he's the CEO of Dashling
so what does that mean it means uh Donald
Sherman is a legacy shareholder
same situation with uh John Kinzer uh he's
actually the former chief financial
officer
uh and he on according to his LinkedIn
profile left as the CFO of HubSpot in
January 2019
also according to his LinkedIn profile uh
he's uh on the board of a number of
companies
and currently he's an operating partner of
Stripes group so again uh as a former uh
employee or management
team uh member John Kinzer uh is a legacy
shareholder next up Michael K Simon uh if
we look at his LinkedIn profile
uh how he's involved in the company he's
actually on the board of directors so you
can reconcile that
uh with the board members on the website
that we looked at earlier so Michael K
Simon uh he's not a
legacy shareholder he's a current
shareholder who's also on the board and
involved with the company
at the current time continuing on uh we
come to Hunter Medley who's actually the
former senior vice president
chief sales officer of HubSpot according
to his uh LinkedIn profile uh he left the
company in July 2019
and previous to that uh he was at
Salesforce and uh he is currently the CEO
of a company called
Veena solutions so Hunter Medley uh is
again another legacy shareholder and then
we come to our search
as to how uh Lawrence Bone is involved in
the company well Lawrence aka Larry Bone
uh was an original
investor in HubSpot pre-IPO when it was a
private company so Larry Bone uh his
company general catalyst
uh invested uh invested five million
dollars uh in HubSpot way back in 2007 and
he also served on the board
now given that the company uh has now been
public for a while and uh there was a lot
of legacy situations
here when we were looking at our insider
stock and stock option ownership not
forgetting that the value of
of these uh stock holdings was pretty
small uh in the bigger picture it probably
means that all of these
guys have been exiting their positions and
paring down their stock holdings over a
number of years
and as part of our process uh we would go
off and just do a little bit of work and
confirm that so what have
we actually learned here well all of the
shareholders in the HubSpot example uh the
additional shareholders
that we discovered uh additional to uh the
current situation where we have the two
co-founders who are the biggest
shareholders all of those additional guys
were legacy situations with the exception
of Michael K Simon who
actually currently serves on the board of
directors so it's interesting that they
still all own stock in
the company but we would have to see if
they've been selling down their stock
holdings from larger positions
now in this case this does not mean that
it's a bearish signal for the stock these
guys helped build the
company and they could just be cashing in
that doesn't mean the stock can't go up
much further
so you do have to use some uh general
knowledge and understanding of uh how
finance and how private to
public companies and ipos work and you do
have to read between the lines and have
some discretion here
just because some key members of
management are paring down their positions
it doesn't mean
that the stock can't go up or it's a
bearish signal for the stock for one they
could just be cashing
in to finance their next project or
retirement and secondly the size of their
stock holding might be so
small that it's actually fairly irrelevant
now on that note after we've looked in our
process
at insider stock and stock option
ownership the next thing we would move on
to is to look at transactions
so we look at a recent transaction history
and we look at the activity of management
and what they've been up to in terms of
trading out of their stock positions
and we try to figure out from management
if they've been light or aggressive in
their selling of their own
stock now again we have to use some common
sense read between the lines here and use
some discretion
even if someone in management has been
aggressive in terms of selling stock they
might be doing it for
other reasons other than for the cynical
reason that they think their own stock is
going to go down
they may just be cashing in and retiring
or moving on to their next project
what this analysis does however is it just
gives us another data point in our overall
process
now with the hubspot example using
fidelity as our source at the time when we
looked at this it showed us
that dharma shah and brian halligan as to
be expected are transacting in the largest
amounts of stock
of insiders and we sorted by market value
and we can see here that the biggest
transaction
took place in december 2020 and that was
dharma shah selling 15.5 million dollars
worth of stock
in that month and the second biggest
transaction was dharma shah again selling
10.1 million dollars
worth of stock in february 2021 we can
also see that our ceo uh mr brian halligan
uh has been making sales
of notional value of between 1 million and
4 million dollars during the year of 2020
now if you remember back to the value of
their entire holdings they were much much
bigger than this
so these sizes of these sales are tiny
compared to their overall holdings this
should give us confidence
that they actually want their stock to
either stay at current levels or go to
higher levels
so they're actually selling but they're
selling very lightly they're not being
aggressive
so the big guys the co-founders they are
still in and they own a lot of stock
now something else that we may do with uh
transactions is to not only sort by market
value
but also sort by date to have a look at
the most recent transactions and when we
do that what we find
is that our current cfo who through
further work is actually an outgoing cfo
she's leaving the company
uh so this is katherine buecker we can see
that she's been active with chip sizes in
the hundreds of thousands of dollars
of dollars now does this mean that it's a
bearish signal for the stock
if the current cfo is leaving the company
and they're selling stock in the hundreds
of thousands of dollars value
not necessarily you would obviously need
to do further work on it and figure out
what she is actually doing
and where she's going and figure out a
probabilistic scenario as to why she's
selling the stock
in this situation the sizes are
insignificant and it's probably or highly
likely that she's financing
the next stage of her life it's nothing
really to write home about what we also
find
when we look at most recent transactions
here in this example uh is that we see
other order types from
dharma shah and brian halligan and they
are disposing of stock not on the open
market now this is likely to be
internal transfer of stock using public
market prices using the market as a
reference for price
and transferring their stock internally to
new members of staff
that are coming into the company or in
fact to the employee compensation pool
now of course we'll never know this a
hundred percent for sure but this is
probably the case
so all of this is fairly reassuring during
our qualitative assessment if we did see
large selling
transactions from insiders this would
obviously be a cause for concern
we would have to do further investigation
and figure out the likely reason the
probabilistic reason why
this is actually happening but remember a
founder selling all of their stock doesn't
mean the stock
can't go up they could just be retiring or
have no particular view on the stock
because they're just
leaving the company a new team can still
10x a stock even after the founder has
left
so when you're doing this qualitative
analysis of looking at uh insider stock
and stock option ownership
and transactions please don't make the
rookie retail trader error thinking that
because someone in
management is selling some stock that it's
a bearish signal automatically for the
stock and that the stock is
going to go down that is a very very low
quality and silly way of thinking
okay so an appraisal of the insider stock
and stock ownership and having a look at
the ownership and also the transactions
is an important part of the overall
qualitative assessment
so just make sure that you make an
appraisal of the insider stock and stock
option ownership
and the transactions
the next thing we're going to look at in
our qualitative assessment is research
analyst estimates and the estimate ranges
and ratings
now in the bigger picture what we're
trying to do here when we're looking at
analyst estimates for a stock
and we're looking at the range of those
estimates and the ratings that analysts
have on stocks on a particular stock
what we're trying to achieve here in the
bigger picture is an understanding of the
expectation of the future
as set by the market
and from a qualitative perspective
it's important for us to understand this
for multiple reasons as you're going to
see as we go through this process
but what we're trying to figure out here
in the bigger picture
is the lay of the land
what does the lay of the land in terms of
expectations
for the stock in the future will actually
look like
and from that analysis we can actually
infer many important data points
so the example we're using here
we're going back to our example earlier of
Abercrombie & Fitch
ANF
and we're using yahoo finance as a source
here
and the first thing we're going to look at
is estimates
and most importantly we're going to be
looking at estimates
for eps and for revenue
and this is a process that you would
follow using it as a template in all
situations
you would just go step by step through the
processes and use this as a template
when you're analyzing individual stocks
and their estimates for eps and revenue
and the ranges of those estimates
so if we look at the table on the left
with Abercrombie & Fitch ANF
we can see the stock price at 37.49
and we can see the table for earnings
estimates
and also the table for revenue estimates
looking forward both on a quarterly basis
in the current year
and looking forward on an annual basis for
subsequent subsequent future years
so we can see from the table straight away
where we are in terms of timing
we are in the current year 2021
so if you think back to our spreadsheets
when we were looking at processing
the data for particular sectors
and stocks within those sectors
if the current year is 2021
then that would be represented in the
column as our eps 1 number
and 2022 would be our eps 2 number
what we're going to concentrate on here
for the purposes of this demonstration
registration is the eps 2 number so we're
going to be looking at 2022 estimates
so forward looking beyond the current
financial year
so we'll be looking at earnings eps in
and we'll also be looking at revenue in
in reality when you're doing this for real
of course you would also consider the eps
1 number as well
but for purposes of demonstration we're
just going to look at 2022 here and you
can utilize
this same type of analysis when you're
looking at the eps 1 number as well
and also of course if you're looking at
revenue in 2022 or more than one year
forward
so the next year and also in the current
year
so in terms of uh analyst estimates and
the range when we look at full year 2022
the eps range is 89 cents at the low end
and a dollar 94 at the high end
and we have 12 analysts covering the stock
so we have 12 analysts that have ratings
so there will be an analyst that is
setting the low end
at 89 cents and an analyst that is setting
the high end at a dollar 94 and 10
analysts in between that
all we have to do to get the mean
consensus
is divide through and we get a dollar 50.
and this has been done for us by our
source yahoo finance
now an interesting step in the process uh
and you would do this uh when you're
looking at this for real
is to actually work out what is the
halfway point between the low end of the
range
and the high end of the range of analysts
estimates and this just gives us a better
understanding
of the distribution of analysts estimates
within that range so our halfway point
here for abercrombie
and fitch 2022 eps estimates our halfway
point in the range is just above a dollar
41.
now with a mean consensus of a dollar 50
that just means that there's more analysts
that are closer
to the high end of the range a dollar and
94 cents than the bottom end of the range
at 89 cents
so in this situation it's quite likely
that the analyst uh who is setting the
bottom of the range at 89 cents
is a negative outlier analyst because the
mean is above the halfway point so the
distribution is skewed
towards the positive moving on to revenue
if we look at revenue uh in 2022 uh the
revenue range is 3.36 billion
to 3.59 billion with a full year mean
consensus of 3.5 billion the halfway point
in the range is 3.475 billion
dollars so again similar to eps and the
distribution there there are more analysts
that are closer to the
the higher end of the range at 3.59
billion versus the low end of the range at
3.36 billion
so again it's likely in this situation
that the analyst who's setting the bottom
end of the range
is a negative outlier is a negative
outlier analyst because the distribution
is skewed to the positive
from our source we also get given a uh
full year mean consensus sales growth
percentage number which
comes in at 12.1 percent now in the bigger
picture uh the mean number for these
ranges uh is meaningful
because there's a decent amount of
analysts covering the stock you will go
through many situations
where you only have two three or four
analysts covering a stock and you'll go
through other
situations where you have 15 20 25
analysts covering a stock and as with
anything the more data points we
have the more statistically significant a
result becomes so the more analysts that
are covering a stock the
more meaningful and likely that the
consensus mean will be accurate or very
close to being accurate
so this is something you'll be dealing
with uh on a regular basis each quarter uh
when you're going into
earnings numbers you'll be looking at
analyst estimates and the range and
figuring out the distribution of the
estimates whether the real distribution is
skewed towards the positive or the
negative or very close to the halfway
point
and the more analysts covering the stock
the more weight we put on it in terms of
accuracy
so of course you're going to have to
repeat the same analysis each quarter for
every stock that you're
considering now you have to remember that
these are analysts estimates so it is what
is expected by the market
now in this situation because we know that
most analysts are at the or near the top
of the range
if abercrombie and fitch a and f guide
lower for 2022 so they guide lower than a
dollar 50 of eps
for 2022 then the stock will likely go
down this will be a disappointment to the
market
and of course these estimates from
analysts will change throughout the year
this is a dynamic
situation analysts are going to change
their eps and revenue estimates based on
new information that
becomes publicly available to the market
something else you will do in this part of
the qualitative analysis
is you will also look at the trend of
estimates changes in the near past so from
our same source yahoo finance
in the last 30 days abercrombie and fitch
has seen four increases in quarterly eps
estimates in the current year
so in 2021 and in the current quarter that
we're sitting in at the time and there's
been two increases in eps
estimates for the following quarter in
2021 and what we can see in the table is
that there's been corresponding
increases uh in the full year 2022 numbers
and in 2023 as well so it looks like the
same analysts
are increasing their full year 22 and 23
numbers as well if we were going through
this process as part of
our qualitative analysis and we were
looking at this through a long lens this
would obviously be great news
however if we're looking through a short
lens we would be very concerned
so as a part of your qualitative
assessment yes you are going to have to
look at analyst estimates and ranges
and do a little bit of work on them and
figure out firstly the range and the
distribution within the range
so the mean consensus versus the halfway
point and figure out what the skew is for
the distribution of
analyst estimates within the range and
secondly look at the change in estimates
and the trend of those
changes in the near past ideally what we
want to be seeing is that the market
agrees with our synopsis
so if we're coming into our qualitative
assessment with a bullish bias we have a
positive outlier
what do we want to see we want to see a
positive skew in the distribution and we
want to see estimates of
forward-looking estimates from analysts
being changed in the near past and
trending upwards
this means the market fundamentally is on
our side and it agrees with our synopsis
now something else you need to look at in
addition to estimates and the range
and having an understanding of that is the
lay of the land in terms of analyst
ratings given to the stock
Using the same source here, Yahoo Finance,
and of course, this will be available with
multiple sources online.
You can see that we get a couple of things
displayed to us in terms of the ratings.
So first of all, we have the descriptors
of the ratings where we have strong buy,
buy, hold, underperform, and sell.
We'll come on to those in a second.
But essentially, we get two things that we
can look at.
Firstly, we get the distribution of those
ratings amongst analysts, across the
analysts.
And secondly, we get how that distribution
has changed in the recent past.
What we also get is an average rating
monitor, so the recommendation rating
monitor as an average.
And we also get the average price target
from analysts, with a range of the price
targets as well.
And recall, the current stock price is
$37.49 at the time of recording.
So let's talk here briefly about the
descriptors of ratings themselves.
So there's essentially three ratings an
analyst can actually give a stock.
It's either going to be a buy rating, a
hold rating, which can also be described
as neutral, or a sell rating.
And strong buy, and strong buy, just means
buy, okay?
And underperform, just means sell.
So if you see the term outperform, it just
means buy.
If you see the term underperform, or even
strong sell, it just means sell.
So the way to look at this is always just
think of it in terms of ratings of buy,
hold, or neutral, or sell.
And what you've also got to remember is
that these ratings are not referring to
outperforming or underperforming the
general stock market.
It's with reference to a relative call on
the stock to the stock's sector.
So if you see a buy rating on a stock, it
does not mean that the analyst is saying
they think this stock is going to
outperform the market.
It means they think that the stock is
going to outperform the sector.
And of course, the opposite is true.
If you locate a stock that has a sell
recommendation, an analyst has a sell
recommendation on that stock, it means the
analyst thinks it's going to underperform
the other stocks in the sector.
So it's underperforming the sector
average.
In addition, what you have to remember is
that when an analyst covers multiple
stocks in a sector, they have to have an
equal number of buy and sell
recommendations.
They can't just have a distribution of
ratings with stocks across a sector where
they're just bullish everything or they
have everything on a hold recommendation.
And it stands to reason if you have a
bunch of stocks in a sector, let's say,
for example, 20, from all of the estimates
out there, the consensus estimates for
forward-looking EPS, for revenue, etc.,
there's obviously going to be a mean
average.
And at any one moment in time, there's
going to be stocks that contribute
positively to that average, and there's
negatively to that average.
It can never be the case that it's any
different to that.
It's always going to be the case.
So when analysts have buy ratings or sell
ratings, what they're actually saying to
you is that their buy ratings are stocks
that they believe will outperform the
sector average,
and their sell ratings are stocks that
they believe will underperform the sector
average.
Now, on top of that, they also have price
targets, and this also sets a range across
the analysts for price targets themselves.
And in our example here with Abercrombie &
Fitch, we can see the low end of the range
for a price target is $22.
The high end of the range is $46, the
average is $34.11, and the stock is
currently trading at $37.49.
And for our recommendation ratings, our
distribution gives us an average of $2.5,
which is somewhere between a hold and a
buy.
Now, we mentioned earlier that with our
ratings, we do get a couple of things.
We get the distribution of ratings, and we
get the distribution changing throughout
time.
What you also can look at is the upgrades,
downgrades, and maintains of ratings in
the near past and throughout history.
And what we see here with Abercrombie &
Fitch is an upgrade, so one upgrade from
neutral rating to buy rating from UBS in
April 2021.
And before that, we see multiple
reiterations of sell or hold ratings, and
the reiteration of sell ratings or
underperform or underweight ratings is
coming from Morgan Stanley and Bank of
America.
The reiteration of a neutral rating comes
previously from UBS, so they reiterated a
neutral rating after initiating as a
neutral, and then they end up upgrading
the rating later on.
Now, something you would do in your
processes is look at the stock price
performance over the near-term past.
So, if we think of the stock price
movement and put into context the
estimates changes, the range, and also the
ratings changes in the context of the
stock price movement,
And if we look at the stock price, it went
from $20 in November 2020 to $37 in April
2021.
And Abercrombie & Fitch, the stock price,
massively outperformed the retail sector.
So, what does that mean?
In terms of the ratings, it means that
analysts were wrong here.
Why?
Because most analysts had this stock on a
hold rating, and big analysts at
investment banks like Bank of America and
Morgan Stanley were reiterating
underperform or underweight ratings during
the time period.
And also, UBS reiterated a neutral rating,
and they upgraded the stock to a buy
rating after the price had moved.
So, when we think of our image display
here on the left-hand side, and we're
looking at the average rating and also the
average price target,
it's very likely that the price target has
moved up to $34.11 from a lower level and
a lower range in response to the stock
price actually going up.
Also, what's interesting is if we think of
the ratings distribution in the context of
the stock price movement over this period,
we can see that the average rating has
actually gone up.
So, if you look at the distribution in
February, we have 17 analysts, and we have
10 hold ratings, we have four underperform
ratings, and we have two sell ratings.
So, that makes 16 out of 17 analysts,
which must mean we had one strong buy.
But if you think of what the average
rating will have been in February, it
would have been hovering around between
underperform and hold.
So, the average rating score on our scale
here on Yahoo Finance in February would
have been somewhere around 3.5.
And then we move into March, and we notice
a few things.
The first thing we notice is that the
amount of analysts covering the stock has
gone down from 17 to 13.
So, four analysts in the market dropped
coverage of the stock.
And what this resulted in was a change in
the distribution, not least because
there's now no longer any sell
recommendations.
The amount of underperforms has gone down
from 4 to 2, and the amount of hold
recommendations has gone down from 10 to
7.
Now, we don't know the exact details of
the analysts from the chart here that
dropped the recommendations or dropped
their coverage,
but it's fairly likely that the guys that
did this were the guys that, first of all,
had sell recommendations
and possibly underperform recommendations.
So, it looks like here that they've
dropped coverage instead of having to go
through the embarrassment of upgrading the
rating on the stock
and admitting that they got it totally
wrong.
So, that's what's likely to be the case
here.
However, of course, we would have to go
away and check the details on that.
Also, what we notice is that there's an
increase in buy ratings or buy and strong
buy ratings.
And in our history table of ratings
changes on the right-hand side, we don't
actually see evidence of that.
So, we probably have to go and check that
to see if it's actually the case.
You can do that by Googling search terms
like ANF upgraded from hold to buy or
neutral to buy.
And then looking in Google News and seeing
what the most recent headlines were with
regards to ratings changes.
But given what we know about this
distribution and how it's changed very
quickly over a one-month period,
it seems likely that whoever upgraded the
stock from a hold to a buy or a strong buy
may have done it very quietly
and not actually put out a press release.
What you need to be careful of here is
obviously trying to work smart and not too
hard.
You know, don't go down huge rabbit holes
and spend lots of time trying to figure
out exactly what ratings
every single investment bank and brokerage
company has on a stock.
Just understand the distribution and the
basics of what it looked like in the past
or in the near past
and what it looks like now, roughly
speaking.
So, that's the situation in March.
And then when we move to April, we see a
decrease in coverage from 13 analysts to
12.
And the analyst that seems to have
disappeared is the analyst or one of the
analysts that in March had an
underperformed rating.
So, that analyst has dropped coverage.
And now we've got seven analysts with a
hold rating.
We've got two with a buy rating.
And we've got two with a strong buy
rating, which leaves us with one analyst
that has an underperformed rating.
So, going through this process, it really
helps us to understand the lay of the land
and putting it into context of the stock
price movement in the near past.
When you go through this process, you're
actually going to learn how analysts have
been predicting
and responding to the actual real live
market.
And in the Abercrombie & Fitch analysis
here, in this example, what we found is
that analysts have got this very wrong
in terms of ratings in the near past.
And also, if you think about what we
looked at earlier with this example, where
we looked at the positive skew in terms of
the distribution for the consensus mean
EPS versus the midpoint
and the consensus mean revenue number
versus the midpoint, and also the
increases in the last 30 days of EPS
estimates,
it's pretty obvious when we put all this
together, the ratings changes, the
estimates, and the stock price movement,
and they are changing their ratings and
upping their estimates to come to the
present situation in response to the stock
price movement
and likely the numbers that the company
has reported and forward-looking guidance
increasing.
So if we look at the stock price movement
here over this time period, so we're
looking from early November to the end of
April.
So from the beginning of November 2020 to
the end of April 2021, and we compare this
performance to the S&P 500 retail sector,
we can see that Abercrombie & Fitch over
this time period significantly
outperformed the S&P 500 retail sector.
And what we've done over this time period
is we've indexed the performance of
Abercrombie & Fitch to a hundred,
and we've also indexed the performance of
the S&P 500 retail sector at the beginning
of the period to a hundred as well.
And you can see that roughly speaking,
Abercrombie & Fitch outperformed the S&P
500 retail sector by a hundred and forty
percent,
which is obviously a huge outperformance
in such a short space of time.
And if we look at the absolute stock
price, so we look at A&F Abercrombie &
Fitch in absolute terms.
If we look back to November, the month of
November 2020, you'll remember that we
picked the base number at that time as
$20.
So it was actually, even at the beginning
of November, we were being conservative
there, because even at the beginning of
November, it was actually around $15.
But anyway, it goes from $15, $20 a share.
So in that region, over the time period,
up to $37.49 at the end of April 2021.
So using $15 as our starting point and
$37.50 as our end point, that's $22.50 on
a $15 stock price.
We're getting a 150 percent return in
terms of performance in this stock over
the time period.
Now, what's the point of all this in terms
of looking at analyst ratings?
What's the point of this example?
What's the point of all of it?
Well, the point is, is that as traders,
what we like to see is that we like to see
room for changes in recommendations.
So in our example, in Abercrombie & Fitch,
six months ago, the landscape will have
looked very, very different.
The average rating would have been around
a hold to underperform ratings, which
means that there was actually, at the
time, room for upgrades, which in
themselves are catalysts that can get the
stock moving.
So if you think of an extreme example,
where every single analyst in the market
has a sell recommendation or underperform
recommendation for their rating, what does
that actually mean?
Well, it actually means that no one can
downgrade the stock.
No one can downgrade their rating because
every analyst in the market has the lowest
rating possible.
What can only happen in that situation is
that analysts can upgrade their rating.
That's the only thing that can happen.
And of course, it's the same situation in
the opposite.
If every single analyst has a strong buy
or buy rating on a stock in the market, no
analyst can actually upgrade their rating
in the future.
In that situation, the only thing that
analysts can do is downgrade their rating.
And this is why we look at the
distribution of ratings for research
analysts.
Because in our qualitative analysis, as
traders, we like catalysts.
We like as many catalysts as possible that
are going to get the stock moving.
And although it's not a prerequisite or an
absolute necessity for it to be there,
it's always nice to see that for our
potential long ideas, we have room for
upgrades.
This, however, doesn't mean that when
we're going through our qualitative
analysis, that if we see all analysts with
a buy rating for a potential long idea,
or we see all analysts with a potential
short idea that we can't actually go long
or short, we just have to be very careful
to understand that in those situations, we
might be entering consensus positioning.
So we have to be cautious, but by going
through this process, going through this
part of the qualitative process, what
we're actually doing here is understanding
the lay of the land.
So we're understanding whether there is
actually room for upgrades or downgrades,
and potentially whether there's extreme
bullish or bearish analyst estimates,
ratings, and therefore sentiment.
When we do have room for upgrades or
downgrades, so when we have room for
upgrades for long ideas, on the upside
with longs,
It means analysts, on the whole are being
too cautious, and when we have room for
ratings changes to the downside for
potential short ideas, it usually means
that the analysts in the market are in
denial.
Either way, although it's not a must-have,
we do like to see this.
We do like to see, as traders, that we
have potential room for upgrades or
downgrades in the way that we're trading.
Why? Because it means analysts are
responding and not actually predicting
like us.
We are taking the position, we are
predicting what's going to happen in the
future, and then analysts are responding
to it, and then providing us with
catalysts, and the stock price is moving
on those catalysts.
What you have to understand about research
analysts is that they are career-driven
corporate salarymen.
Again, they are career animals, and they
very rarely stick their neck out and make
a big call.
They just want to get paid, and they just
want to put their kids through private
school.
Now, of course, we don't go out there and
look for situations to generate trade
ideas where we see stocks that have all
sell ratings and all buy ratings and go
against the analysts.
That's just ridiculous.
Of course not.
You have to go through your processes
properly.
You identify your positive and negative
outliers, and then you go on to the
qualitative analysis, and this is one part
of it.
This is one part of it, guys, where you're
understanding the distribution of ratings,
you're understanding the range of
estimates, and you're understanding the
positive or negative skew from the market
when we look at mean consensus estimates
versus midpoints.
We don't use one part of our trade idea
generation process in isolation to
generate trade ideas.
We obviously use all of the entire pro
trader systematic process, and this is
just a small part of it.
We don't use one part of it.
From analysts and understanding how that
has evolved over time in the near past,
you are
getting a handle on the current situation
of market expectation and on top of that,
you
are getting a handle on whether there is
room for upgrades, downgrades or indeed
ratings changes
in the future that may provide future
catalysts.
You are understanding and identifying more
important qualitative parameters for the
stock itself.
So in the future, if you have a position
in the stock, you can digest news that's
coming
out far more effectively.
So for example, with Abercrombie & Fitch,
if you went through all of this analysis,
if
you recall, we had $1.50 of earnings per
share as an estimate from the market for
2022.
We know that the current distribution of
analyst ratings is skewed towards a hold
rating, but
it's somewhere between a hold and a buy
rating.
And we know that the current stock price
is $37.49 and the average price target for
analysts
on a very wide range is $34.11.
So what happens if we have a position in
this stock and the company guides to an
EPS number
for 2022 when they report their quarterly
earnings in 2021?
What if they guide their 2022 number to
$1.75?
Well, we are on top of everything and we
know that analysts are going to have to
upgrade
the stock in response.
They're all going to also have to up their
estimates and up their price targets.
And the stock is going to go up a lot.
So in terms of qualitative processing,
you've just got to be on top of research
analyst estimates
and the range of those estimates.
You need to be on top of the positive or
negative mean consensus skew relative to
midpoints.
You need to be on top of recent history or
near term estimates changes.
And of course, we like to see some
evidence that we've got the wind blowing
in the right
direction.
And you need to be on top of analyst
ratings, the distribution of those
ratings, how they've
been changing through near past time, the
average rating in terms of the average of
the distribution
and also price targets.
All of this is going to keep you on top of
the parameters that you need to understand
for
the stock in the real world.
And moving forward through time, if you
have a position on, as the dynamic is
changing,
you're going to understand how to digest
all of this information as fundamental
news comes
out and these parameters move.
Now we've obviously been through a lot in
this video and the previous video on
qualitative analysis.
So let's summarize everything here.
We obviously started with the most
important thing, which is identification
of KPIs.
So again, we're not here going to give you
the entire list of KPIs for every sector
and subsector
in the GICS or NAICS classifications.
This is just something that you're going
to have to do for yourself by piecing the
evidence
together from annual and quarterly
reports, company presentations, and
earnings call transcripts.
And you need to do it on a case by case
basis until you get good at it.
And when you start out, you're going to
end up with a full KPI list for a
particular stock.
And by default, those same KPIs are going
to apply across the sector.
And as you've seen, once you've identified
KPIs for a particular stock, by default,
you end
up with an inferred management operating
plan for the stock.
Now, not only KPIs for a particular stock,
an inferred management operating plan, and
also
KPIs across a sector make up a full
qualitative analysis.
You need to add in qualitative market
dynamics, such as management to themselves
and their track record, the board, insider
stock info, and an appreciation of
research analyst estimates, ranges, and
ratings.
So, adding on all of this qualitative
analysis to your quantitative analysis is
absolutely essential, guys.
And obviously, you need to be doing this
work yourself.
You need to be going through all of this
yourself.
Remember the ITPM principles,
self-sustainability, work ethic, free
information, and working smart, not hard.
So, use videos 30 and 31 to achieve a full
qualitative analysis when you're doing
your work.
Use them as a template and use the case
studies and apply the steps and processes
on a case-by-case basis until you build up
your own database of KPIs.
And there's a discipline here to always
remember.
When you're achieving a full qualitative
assessment of KPIs and an inferred
management operating plan, and also the
qualitative market dynamics, always refer
back to valuation from your quantitative
process.
And ask the question, does the qualitative
assessment support or deny valuation and
my positive or negative outlier status
that I identified in the quantitative
process when I selected the stock to do
work on?
When the qualitative assessment supports
our positive or negative outlier status,
we are in business.
Our trade idea is in business.
We then do further work.
If our qualitative assessment denies our
valuation status, our positive or negative
outlier status, then we have a problem
because we are then clueless as to why
valuation is where it is.
We can't take positions in stocks, long or
short, simply because we've identified
them as positive or negative outliers in
the quantitative phase without
understanding what is actually driving
valuation and having a full handle on it
and have an expectation for the future.
We need our qualitative assessment to
actually support our valuation.
And then we are moving one step closer to
having a full trade idea.
So guys, those are the steps for the
qualitative analysis that we've covered in
the last two videos.
Let's go back to the desk for a recap.
Okay, guys, so welcome back to the desk
once again.
The last few videos, what did we look at?
We looked at qualitative analysis.
So let's have a recap of what we looked at
the last few videos.
So the first thing we looked at was KPIs,
key performance indicators, and actually
where to find them.
Primarily, we're going to get them at the
investor relations website.
However, let's use a little bit of common
sense here.
We obviously go through an entire
quantitative process before we actually
arrive at this stage at the qualitative
analysis.
And by simply going through the
quantitative process, we are obviously
going to pick up little tidbits of
qualitative information as we go through
that process.
It's kind of unavoidable.
We are going to get some information
that's qualitative along the way.
The key here is understanding the
difference between a quantitative metric
like revenue, earnings, and anything
that's a measure on financial statements,
and a qualitative metric.
So an underlying business driver metric or
measure, okay?
And when you actually understand that and
understand the difference and split them
out properly, your process just becomes
more systematic.
So with KPIs, what are we doing?
We are looking under the hood.
We're looking under the bonnet of the car.
And what we have to remember all the time
is that KPIs are an inference of the
management operating plan, and the
management operating plan drives future
revenue and earnings.
So we go through this KPI identification
process so we can put those metrics into
the context of future guidance of revenue
and earnings, and then we gauge whether
there's going to be an upwards or
downwards revision of guidance for revenue
and earnings.
Now, the investor relations website,
that's not the only place where we can
find KPIs.
When you go through the identification
process, you can take an extra step and go
to the earnings call transcripts to fill
in any missing blanks, any missing
information that you may have overlooked
or may not be included on the investor
relations website.
So we can go to past earnings call
transcripts, go through them and look for
all the clues and pull out in all the
information and infer a management
operating plan from those KPIs.
Now, of course, earnings releases and
earnings call transcripts going forward.
They're very important for us as traders
and you're going to you're going to you're
going to have positions over earnings in
the future.
And you definitely want to be on top of
earnings when they come out and be going
through them and also going through the
earnings call and the call transcripts.
Very, very, very important because you're
going to have positions over earnings.
So, of course, you need to get used to
this process of looking at earnings
information and earnings call transcripts
because that gives you practice to what's
coming up in the future and it makes you
better at processing them.
So, if you have a current position going
into an earnings day, what's going to
happen?
The earnings and the earnings call
transcript information is just going to
confirm or deny your fundamental work and
hence your current position.
You're going to have to make decisions on
the position based on this information,
based on revenue, earnings and even the
information from KPIs.
OK, and you're either going to run the
position, you're going to add to it or
you're going to trade out of the position.
Now, if you've got no position going into
earnings, the information on the financial
metrics, so revenue, earnings and
additional financial measures, plus any
discussion about the KPIs that moves the
needle of the KPIs.
If you have no position going into
earnings, what's going to happen?
You're going to decide whether you're
going to have a position or not after
earnings based on that information.
So, it's very important to practice this
stuff and just going through the process,
the qualitative process, you'll be better
at identifying KPIs and whether the needle
is going to move.
Also, at the qualitative phase, we looked
at management track record, the board of
directors, the quality of the board.
We looked at insider stock and stock
option ownership, and we looked at
research analyst estimates, range and
ratings.
And for the qualitative info for
management track record, board of
directors, stock ownership and stock
option ownership, what position you're
intending to have is very important.
So, what lens you're looking through when
you're assessing this information, this
qualitative information.
So, for example, if you're potentially
looking to go long, what is your primary
concern here?
Your primary concern is you want to make
sure that there's no red flags in any of
this qualitative information.
So, red flags from management track
record, red flags from the board of
directors, and also the stock ownership,
option ownership, and recent trading in
the stock and options.
If you're intending to go long and you
start uncovering red flags, you obviously
have to do a bit more further work, do
more of a deep dive on that information.
And if that information ends up putting
you off being long, then that's totally
fine.
So, just go through that process.
If everything agrees, however, that
everything's okay, there's no red flags,
then it's probably going to be a situation
where you move on to the next stage of the
process.
On the short side, what are we looking
for?
What are we concerned with?
Well, we actually, if we're looking to go
short a stock, we look at all of this
information in the qualitative phase, and
we uncover red flags.
That's great for us.
But, if there's no red flags, it might
make you think twice.
It's all situational.
You just have to go through it and figure
it out.
For research analysts, the estimates, the
range of estimates, and research analyst
ratings,
because we know that research analysts are
essentially career-driven, risk-averse,
political animals,
because we know that, most of the time,
their ratings, their price targets, they
are lagging the stock price.
So, ideally, what we want to see when we
look at this information, we want to see
that there's room for longs, for example.
We want to see room for upside.
And for shorts, we want to see that
there's room for downside.
So, for longs, we want to see that there's
room for upside, so upgrades.
So, when we go through this overall
process, guys, the qualitative process,
what we're looking for,
what we want to see is evidence that the
qualitative assessment supports our
fundamental quantitative work, okay?
That's what we're looking for when we're
going through this whole process, okay?
The information supporting on the
qualitative side, the quantitative work
that we've already done, okay?
So, go through the qualitative process, in
addition to the quant process, it's very
important that you do that.
Now, we're going to move on to the next
stage of the PTM video series,
the next stage of the trade idea
generation process.
It's a very, very important part.
We're now going to be looking at
catalysts.
And catalysts is what sets apart a trade
idea from an investment idea.
Very important to remember that as we move
forward into the next section.
So, let's go over to the next video, and
I'll see you back at the desk very soon.
we'll see you back at the next video, and
I'll see you back at the next video.
Thank you.